[Music]
alright I have emphasized this over and
over again by the way welcome to Vegas
the decades-old assault charges this is
36 years ago against professor Christine
Ford she's making allegations against
judge Cavanaugh of course they must be
taken seriously her story deserves to be
told and Republicans and President Trump
they have been treating this situation
with the pure seriousness that it
deserves
now the Judiciary Committee Chairman
senator Grassley of Iowa Senate
Republicans they've been doing
everything they can do to accommodate
Professor Ford they have reopened the
hearings they've invited the professor
to appear before Congress they have
offered a public hearing they have
offered a private hearing they have
reached out by phone email and more for
background they even offered to apply
Senate staff anywhere within the United
States to meet Ford for a private
interview so far professor Ford a
left-wing lawyer have not agreed to any
of this and according to an email
obtained by The Washington Post she
definitely will not appear before the
committee on Monday but may be open to a
later date if the Senate agrees to her
terms
we're gonna watch this unfold now
meanwhile judge Kavanagh well he's
already testified by the way under
threat of perjury he's agreed to testify
wherever whenever under oath in front of
you the American people in fact he's
agreed to testify this coming Monday the
Democrats don't seem to care they have
thrown a principle we hold so dear due
process the presumption of innocence out
the window
they've already convicted Kavanagh based
on one allegation
according to them and the mob rule by
which many in the left are governed
Cavanaugh is guilty just by an
accusation this is dangerous for every
American and according to them he has no
right to be believed at all not even a
right to be heard according to senator
gillibrand
no right of the presumption of innocence
this is not the American Way watch this
the Senate shouldn't simply rely on
hearing two conflicting accounts and
decide well we're okay with not knowing
we're okay with the fact that we might
be putting a someone who committed
attempted rape on the Supreme Court the
United States I believe her listen first
of all anybody who comes forward at this
point to be prepared to testify in the
United States Senate against someone
who's being nominated to one of the most
powerful positions of the United States
government that takes an extraordinary
amount of courage not only do women like
dr. Ford who bravely comes forward need
to be heard but they need to be believed
they need to be believed I just want to
say to the men in this country just shut
up and step up do the right thing let me
just say right at the outset I believe
dr. Ford I believe the survivor here
there's every reason to believe her she
has come forward courageously and
bravely I believe her I stand with her
and hope she shows up on Monday do you
hope that she should be bullied into
this scenario where it's a he-said
she-said it's a sham hearing and I don't
think she should participate in it they
have all taken sides
they've all made a decision they don't
even want to give Judge Cavanaugh an
opportunity to give his side taking cues
from their allies in the Democratic
Party the corrupt mainstream media in
this country in what is a disgusting
despicable display they have now picked
up their pitchforks their torches and
their convicting judge Kavanagh they
not an accusation no presumption of
innocence from your left-wing destroy
trump media take a look what you're
seeing is this stealth intimidation
campaign I really think that's what's
going on here is to send a message to
Professor Blasi that the world is
aligning against you or at least the
power structure of the world is aligning
against you I am blown away before I saw
this stuff I'm like oh come on what
could be in this guy's yearbook like a
little nonsense this is six stuff right
the devil's triangle in your yearbook
forever and ever
please people in Congress right now and
not Senate Judiciary Committee these
white men old by the way I'm not
protecting women they're protecting a
man who is probably guilty I can give a
scenario for both of you the D
Republicans will not like the accuser
dr. Freud appears on television and
gives their full story to a reporter to
an anchorperson
and it's deadly its deadly and they're
stuck with this confirmation I don't
think they're going to be very happy
with that scenario
it's definitely attempted rape but III
don't see it any other way
all right not to be undone the left-wing
radical group moveon.org
they produce this ad full of celebrities
I love you too hi
anyway we're in Vegas but these huh
they're also more than happy to ignore
the rule of law they're rushing to
judgment they're politicizing this they
don't believe in due process let's take
a look
dear professor Ford do professor Ford
dear professor Ford we know how
difficult it is to stand up to powerful
people we want to thank you for publicly
sharing your story of sexual violence as
members of the Senate determine whether
Supreme Court nominee but have you ever
known red Cavanaugh red Cavanaugh should
serve as justice justice this context is
critical the behavior you described was
wrong wrong wrong
and runs directly Turner DUP holding the
law FMOD justice he should not be
confirmed he should not be confirmed he
should not be confirmed we could also
says I began overwhelming it was
sustained attack her she was shared on a
national stage without your permission
you should be the decision maker about
how our story is shared and ever we
applaud your courage in coming forward
and we will be with you as you face the
inevitable backlash the inevitable
members- oh my gosh you are strong you
are a survivor for survival our survivor
the millions of us have your back
you and your testimony are credible you
and your testimony are credible you and
your testimony you're credible we
believe
we believe you
your sisters signed your sisters
[Music]
all right so the big question what would
happen if a conservative group came out
and said those words except they believe
judge Cavanaugh they said judge
Cavanaugh is credible can you imagine
the outrage from the left this is not a
game this controversy is not about
politics should never be about politics
it should be about ascertaining the
truth these are real people real
families real kids real wives real lives
involved in all of this now professor
Ford has received death threats we're
very sorry to hear that
that should never happen in this society
so to judge Cavanaugh and his wife the
most despicable death threats themselves
this is unacceptable in America today
the courageous keyboard warriors out
there they need to stop and they need to
stop now meanwhile is perfectly clear
the left is using what is a serious
allegation from 36 years ago that has
not been proven to use this as a
political bludgeoning tool using it
politically and according to Politico a
well-known Democratic operative is now
advising professor Ford we know that her
attorney is very inconsistent on this
issue - an after Paula Jones she
supported Al Franken senator Feinstein
is claiming that the media somehow outed
professor Ford with information that
only Feinstein and her fellow Democrats
had access to I don't believe them
they're the only ones that had the
information and Senate Democrats won't
even show Senate Republicans since July
the unredacted letter where Ford makes
her first allegations why won't they
allow the Republicans to see this this
is now some sort of political game and
it's not these are real lives in play
here Democrats they don't want to
confirm judge Cavanaugh they never
wanted him to be confirmed we saw how
they acted during the hearings we see
how they're acting now now this is why
every American has a right to be
skeptical tonight we know the Democratic
Party we know their track record on
claims of sexual misconduct
it is beyond suspect now take for
example right now not 36 years ago
congressman keith Ellison he is the
Deputy Chair number two guy of the
Democratic Party in August Oh a month
ago his ex-girlfriend went public with
claims that keith Ellison congressman
Ellison physically abused her on
multiple occasions including one
instance where she claims he violently
dragged her through the house screaming
bleep get the bleep get out of my house
now despite these allegations recently a
month ago
Ellison goes on to easily win the
party's nomination to be the next
Minnesota Attorney General now think
about this she claims he physically and
mentally abused her over and over again
and guess what prominent Democrats line
up in support believe Cavanaugh's
accuser you're hard-pressed to find any
Democrats standing behind Ellison's
ex-girlfriend that proves it's politics
I don't hear from Kirsten Gillibrand
haven't heard from Camilla Harris
haven't heard from Adam shifty shift
virtually nobody
that means this is political but there's
more Ellison's ex-girlfriend she just
tweeted that the entire Democratic Party
they wouldn't take her claim seriously
despite even a doctor's report
indicating this abuse happen instead she
had to tweet out the
and see smeared threatened and isolated
her and the DNC chairman Tom Perez well
he said that he's still proud that he
made Ellison the Deputy DNC chair do not
see the hypocrisy and double standard
so the DNC Ellison we've called them
they refused to answer our repeated
attempt for comment another Democrat
that exposes the blatant double standard
he walks the halls of Congress look at
him there sherrod Brown of Ohio now take
a look at this new political ad it
details the abuse allegations against
him and his by his then-wife
these are all court records take a
listen
now senator sherrod Brown is facing his
own me to movement from his past these
court records show sworn evidence that
Browns
ex-wife accused him of abusing her she
said Brown assaulted her a judge had to
issue a restraining order later she said
Brown violated the court order of
pushing shoving and bullying her Brown
claims it's a family matter but his
ex-wife like other victims has a right
to be believed this senator had to
resign when evidence emerged he
mistreated women why is Senator Brown
different sorry saying hi to people so
where are the Democrats this is serious
lining it up against I just got this
thrown to me by the way lining up
against Senator Brown this is a serious
topic where are they now with that
refuting any of those horrible claims
even his wife is supporting him
politically but that's up to her but
those court papers remain then you got
senator Cory Booker Spartacus himself
gearing up clearly for a presidential
run for the Democratic Party 1992 he
actually wrote a column in the Stanford
daily detailing how he groped a woman
when he was a teenager would quote with
the top guns slogan ringing in my head I
slowly reached for her breast after
having my hand pushed away once I
reached my mark
that's from senator Booker's spartacus
now calling on Cavanaugh's vote to be
delayed what a hypocrite his office
called the story a right wing attack
though
were his words and next up how could you
ever forget the most notorious sexual
predator inside the Democratic Party
Bill Clinton himself here's what just a
few of Bill Clinton's accusers had to
say about the former president watch
this you describe the scene where he was
biting on your lip and then when it was
all over he was leaving I said you
better put some ice on that
yeah in casually put on his sunglasses
and walked out the door it was a
terrible ordeal for me and I no woman
should be subjected to it it was an
assault he assaulted you yes he and he
touched grabbed fondled and kissed you
asked against your wealth and it's an
allegation that is not made by one woman
it's made by multiple yes I said well I
may need to be going or something and
they saying you know he pulled down his
he said and pulled pulled down his pants
his whole everything and he was exposed
and I said I'm not that kind of girl and
I need to be getting back to my to my
desk
you know what she worked for Bill
Clinton at the time he dropped his pants
exposed himself said kiss it
Juanita Broderick was about rape one day
to Broderick said this this week where's
my FBI investigation all of these same
senators feigning moral outrage they
said nothing in the case of Bill Clinton
in fact he was beloved by most of his
colleagues many that are still in the
Senate despite what is a long long long
track record of exposing himself an
allegation of rape groping grabbing
fondling touching kissing against the
woman's will and the worst day of her
life
Feinstein Schumer Dickey Durbin the rest
of them so many other Democrats they
enthusiastically support everything
Clinton even voted against his
impeachment and they all thought the man
that just heard described was perfectly
fit to hold the highest office in the
land but not judge Kavanagh one instance
one person no evidence nothing from 36
years ago and they rushed to judgment
there's no due process and of course in
this particular case an accusation is
definitive they believe but they haven't
heard for the other side and I believe
we have the presumption of innocence
they're ready to lock up judge Cavanaugh
and throw away every other key fact in
his life in the last four decades but
when it comes to any Democrat the party
is more than happy to sweep those
allegations under the rug not take them
seriously the mainstream media backs
them up every step of the way they
should be ashamed tonight but they're
not Democrats are not the party of women
that they claim it's also the party of
Clinton and Ellison and Weinstein and
Weiner and others we'll have more on
this throughout the show but we do have
huge big breaking news also tonight the
hills John Solomon Sarah Carter also
making a shocking discovery tonight even
more struck texts have and emails have
been on earth and this time
casting a suspicious light on the Obama
administration according to a text from
January 3rd 2017 struck texting page
quote he like us is concerned with
oversharing doesn't want clapper giving
CR cuts to the White House
all political just shows our hand and
potentially makes enemies now are
unclear what CR cuts stands for but it
could very well mean classified raw
intelligence in other words according to
Solomon's reporting tonight high-ranking
FBI agent Peter struck is concerned that
clapper of the Director of National
Intelligence the Obama White House up to
the President himself could potentially
weaponize intelligence and use it
against political enemies the same
clapper whose views anti-trump vitriol
every night and at his cushy gig at fake
news CNN and by the way these texts
occurred during a critical time less
than three days before the Intel
community released a report claiming
pro-trump
Russian interference in our elections
John Solomon and Sarah Carter will break
it all down tonight for us it's just one
more piece of evidence that those at the
highest levels in government involved in
an effort to prevent Trump from ever
getting elected and then destroy the
president after the election and sadly
tonight we still have people working in
our bloated federal bureaucracy actively
working against the president bragging
about it and are proud of it